fear the walking dead returns on August
21st for the second half of its second
season otherwise known as season to be
or maybe it's a case of not to be for
our fractured family as they struggle to
survive on the post pandemic West Coast
if you're not familiar it's the
companion series to one of the most
popular TV shows of all time The Walking
Dead and it's incredibly successful in
its own right with over 10 million
people tuning in it's got the bragging
rights of being the most-watched series
premiere in basic-cable history to
celebrate its return here's five things
you need to know about fear The Walking
Dead only brain-dead zombies assume fear
The Walking Dead is a spin-off in the
traditional sense of the word it may be
set in the same universe at almost the
same time and follow people living
through the same catastrophe but
according to Robert Kirkman creator of
The Walking Dead and fear The Walking
Dead it's technically not a spin-off
because they're not spinning off any of
the characters this is no better call
Saul or Joey and certainly no Frasier
Kirkman fled it will be another group of
characters surviving in another part of
the world and it's not going to use any
of the core cast from our show the show
will continue uninterrupted as if the
other show doesn't exist
which is why we shouldn't expect a
crossover anytime soon if at all via The
Walking Dead showrunner Dave Erickson
has pretty much buried that idea when
asked to PaleyFest his response was no
that's the one straight answer I can
give you the chronology is so far apart
and there's a continent between them
fear is set on the west coast whereas
The Walking Dead is set in all Atlanta
Georgia so there's a whole continent to
cross on foot also there's a small
matter of timeline fear starts just as
the undead outbreak is breaking out
whereas Walking Dead starts long after
people started nibbling on each other
for funsies Erikson says from a
narrative standpoint with The Walking
Dead being six seasons in and going on
seven I don't think we'll ever quite
catch up with them so chronologically it
would be difficult
as well which is of course a massive
shame but we're still holding out hope
some slight spoilers here but let's talk
a little about the mysterious Victor
strand well-dressed tick Aston Martin
tick access to a big-ass yacht named
abigail double tick well in order to add
some authenticity to the show
actor Colman Domingo actually underwent
yacht training you know I got my sea
legs actually which is pretty cool
because I had to go to Yacht training in
San Diego to just learn how to the
operations of the yacht and what I would
need and even being in spencer's those
are the great skills you can get and
learning new things about myself I had
no idea and I actually would like a boat
so if anybody like to give me but I
think about I think give me about
another I'm gonna Bible that's one thing
somebody give me about there's been a
number of Walking Dead video games of
varying degrees of quality from the very
very good you've been
all by yourself through this yeah I want
my parents to come home now I think that
might be a little while to quite
honestly the pretty bad
Roland Earl in a game what can be better
than that
fear The Walking Dead has a mobile
endless run a game but nothing bigger
yet but it turns out the cast are
totally up for it alycia debnam-carey
who plays Alyssia says we've already
signed up for it in a way because we've
done full-body scans for potential video
game releases and for action figure
dolls so far I haven't seen anything
come to fruition but I mean hey it's
probably not hard to imagine it would
come down that path The Walking Dead
comic book was going for around seven
years before it graced the small screen
meaning they had a load of characters
and story arcs to cover with beer though
there is no comic book the story and
characters are totally original and
according to the cast that is a really
good thing yeah I think not having comic
book material is actually works in our
favor in a way I mean it's brilliant for
the original it kind of is very exciting
for fans but for us it leaves room to be
unexpected and to have the advantage of
the fans not knowing I've been able to
frame the character of strand because he
there's no blueprint for him I was given
in this this incredible language by our
writing team and then it's my job to try
to create something that's unique that's
fresh that is ultimately something that
only I can bring to it so that's
exciting that we have know that we have
no map it really to go off of we're just
like we're creating this thing out of
thin air and like hoping that audiences
go along for the ride so there we are
five cool facts about via The Walking
Dead for more on the show make sure you
stay tuned to youtube.com slash GameSpot
and for goodness sake make sure you keep
your eye out for any infected who might
be walking around